helen is with us to start off this hour
in Houston Texas hi Helen how are you
I'm just fine and you better than I
deserve what's up I got too much money
in my checking and savings account well
let me give you another ass you can just
say you can whip up you can just send it
to me I'll give you an address we don't
want you to be burdened with that Helen
so how much money is in your account
sweetie Wow I'm probably about 35,000
over the 150,000 guarantees between it
and I don't really know what to do with
it just leave it there CDs aren't giving
anything I got a good eye ra and a stock
mutual fund how much is in all of that
Oh quite a bit over a million no not
quite okay but it's getting close okay
good for you well done I have no debt
except my expenses I own my own home my
car and I retired in 2008 and I don't
spend money so how old are you 77 okay
um well way to go hero you killed it
you've done a great job with the money
I'm so proud of you you're a millionaire
you ever thought about that well no not
really in that quite I know what I'm
doing pretty good for my age no you're
doing good by any age I'll just tell you
so here's the thing the only downside of
that money being in there is it's not
got the FDIC insurance as you said
you're over the limit on that and that's
the only downside it's not earning any
money as the other downside but you've
got plenty of other money that's earning
money and so you could do one of two
things you could leave it and say it's
not going to earn me much it just gives
me a little extra comfort because I like
a big pile of cash handy if I want some
or if you want to move some of that
money you can move some of it into
mutual funds if you wanted to and you
know
I've got enough in the shop parking
because I don't want to then don't do it
do anymore risk that's fine then don't
do it because there's no there's only
two ways to go
risk and make more no risk and make
nothing and right now you got the no
risk and you're making almost nothing 1%
right and so you're not going to make a
bunch but that's ok you're done great if
you want to just let it sit there I
wouldn't worry about it is it in a bank
that's decent
oh yeah ok I wouldn't worry about it I'd
probably just loose it there based on
talking to you I wouldn't sweat it a bit
I think you've done a great job let me
ask you do you mind if I ask you a
question go right ahead
did you inherit all of that money or did
you guys save it up through your working
life save it up during my working life
so you started off with nothing
basically yes ok you start off with two
hundred thousand or something like that
oh no I started off just putting aside
every month out of my slim paycheck when
I first started working in 59 okay
alright and were you married no so
you've been single your whole life bang
on my home how I and what did you what
was your career
I like for Lester nerf okay alright and
what was your average income during your
working life Oh probably around average
maybe around 50,000 what was the most
you ever made uh ninety five thousand so
you've got almost you got over a million
dollars total including your 401k or
mutual funds all the different parts and
pieces and this cash that we're talking
about totals up over a million dollars
I'm wanting young people listening to
this that are 27 to hear how it's done
this lady's a nurse she never made over
a hundred thousand but she saved money
every month and invested I'm guessing in
your 403b right uh when I first started
up until the sixties and said well the
seventies there was no kind of pension
not all I donated no there wasn't what
did you put that money in during that
time I put it in individual
omelettes CDs okay and then when
everything went busted in what 78 I
rolled it over into an annuity and then
I started working for somebody that I
had a pension and then we went to 401k
yeah and I always put in the maximum
amount okay while making 80 70 80 90
thousand dollars a year all right way to
go well I just wanted these young people
to hear the formula of how you become a
millionaire because some people are
watching television and they think all
millionaires inherited their money and
most of them are you
you're the prototypical millionaire in
North America you worked your tail off
you saved money and you lived on less
than you made that makes you a hero in
my book oh well thank you so right now
I'm on Social Security and my
investments and it provides me with a
good flexible income oh yeah you're
doing time I don't spend money it just
keeps building yes well maybe you ought
to spend some I think you've earned the
right
I just hate spending I hate shopping
well have you traveled oh yeah I do
travel a lot okay where's the coolest
place you've been well my family lives
in Las Vegas area so I go there Creek
frequently which should I allow myself a
certain amount to give to the casinos to
donate to the casino I love it so what's
the most you've ever lost at the casino
Oh probably about 600 oh wow you went
vague I love it it's fun mr. Winn what's
the best house what's the most exotic
vacation you ever took um
Australia and New Zealand oh that's nice
when did you do that uh nine e any money
all right by then you were already
almost a millionaire yeah I love it you
are something else Alan I'm honored to
speak with you thank you for taking time
to call in and and if I were in your
shoes I would just leave that extra
money sitting there it's giving you more
comfort there than it
any place that it's invested and you
have earned the right to enjoy your
money as well as to be generous with it
and so very very very well done you are
a prototypical millionaire folks
listening to the show Helen is the real
world
when you say you're going to punish the
rich people that's who you're talking
about you should be ashamed of
yourselves
you've left wing nut jobs this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and say you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you